you guys ready well you just broke that
from cash oh well at least I know it's
dirty well there it is ladies and
gentlemen it's right it's Monday I just
fit sometimes I go I go
when chin claps us in I go I get a
little like a feeling that here we go
I'm like here we go and there it is
you know I'm saying there did you know
like when I land when I land in a town
where I'm gonna go do my stand-up okay
like say this Thursday in Vancouver or
or in Utah okay okay when I land people
feel something shift right oh here we go
they go they little oh he's here he's
here he's there right we good holy yeah
when I walk when I went to open the door
and I come out with a with a boner I'm
about to make some love and the dudes
are waiting they go he's there I don't
know dude I don't know if there are
dudes it's cuz usually I'm really high
on ketamine dude are you gonna you at
all hungover from the fake beta last
night I will get this morning a hung oh
okay so I got a drink because I want
Bobby wine lavon's wine I had a whiskey
oh yeah whiskey that's let's talk to you
and I smoked that's what'll kill you
yeah hi
so because I was I'm playing for six
hours now I'd sit another four hours
right after I spent 12 hours sitting
yeah I knew I was dehydrated so I sipped
that wine real slow and ate just a
little little bit of cheese you had a
good around the cheese cuz I was feeding
you I got hungry I got home I was
feeding you Rogan Neddy cheese now you
were the mount you were that you were
the Mouse King you were the Mouse King I
was a little I was a little nibbler and
you guys were my myspace I spaced it out
but i saw you take down that whiskey I
saw you take down the weed notice how I
pass on the weed and I'm sorry I've
taken down that wine which was damn
tasty wine god it was good one in cheese
I think that was some good wine
especially the first bottle and then
there was a moment when I couldn't
really hear anyone's voices and I was
just staring at the screen and I was
like oh I'm high as a kite I has and
I've decided think we you and I talked
after if I companion after our three and
a half that's when we get Eddie going on
our two adversities we were there for
we're there from six well you I was
there I got there 6:30 you start at six
ten really yes papa those are three not
far along the 959 what yeah I'm too flew
by sure did
I was high I was drunk I was eating
cheese as I'm gonna grab it laughing
yeah yeah you better wait murmuring you
and [ __ ] Rosen start talking about
Teslas and ganged up do this there's
again I was high in drunk so I got the
[ __ ] mountain lion thing oh let's be
honest I started the baby mount line yet
murdered the bow that's right head and
rogues like it was an 85-pound by a five
pound man I want that guy my podcast now
think so bro G we brought it up he's
like 40 you can refine 80 35 to 40
pounds get the [ __ ] out here with your
starving baby mountain life poor little
things there's a fun time though right
the funnest I truly enjoy that well it's
the only time that you know you don't
get a lot of hangout time in life when
you're busy I don't see Rogen no I don't
mean I never really hang out I don't
really well you get grabbed lunch after
a show wouldn't unless did I see you at
the Comedy Store we really don't get
families right now really to hang right
now that's kind of our hangout that's
our hangout and that dumb time you say
some outlandish [ __ ] especially when
there's booze I take my shirt off and
start throwing punches this did you have
the same body as like how do I look that
I look all right pretty good man I did I
cuz I was like maybe I look super white
and skinny let me like white but yeah
you guys did have the same body
I look are cable you took your shirt off
there though I know same body hey man
good fights cane I was a hold on how was
Palm Beach Palm Beach was the best I've
ever I sold so well and and I had such a
blast you know cuz I'm writing new stuff
did you did you stay in the part where I
said the Hilton right across the street
grace is great it's great I love that
gig I absolutely love like the best case
you just walk Jimmy Burke down Oh from
New York correct Jimmy was out there we
we ha awfully quiet I figured something
was out that's it
played some tennis oh damn yep took took
a private as you know from from Chavez
an American Top Team had a placer go
there he did he watched you just watch
he had Dustin and Mike Brown of course
Jimmy Burke the great rock on tour he
had Dustin and and a dozen prey and Mike
Brown basically enraptured
his one telling stories he tells great
stories along Jimmy and got them both on
philosophize this which is this awesome
podcast where you can if you want to
learn philosophy he breaks it down to
chewable nuggets that's cool so they
were all they were all about it hey
they're so great cuz Mike Brown I think
was Dustin Poirier goes this guy is this
guy's a great conversationalist I go
that's right dude oh yeah that's in New
York yeah yeah the best
that's the prince in New York young man
who doesn't love Jimmy there's no one
who doesn't know it all those dude he
will ingratiate himself so cool he came
down to Florida that's the gangster
Jamesburg yes just I love that
[ __ ]
he's neck couldn't be longer his neck is
a huge liability well there it is
there he is not the guy on the left the
guy on the right oh that's Jim Burke
that long is he single still he's broke
okay sure is single still has got no
eyebrows and his neck is about four feet
long
he's a he's them he's a man giraffe um
but he's charming and rates him to know
him is to love him to know him is to
love the novel story doing yeah and one
of those guys who would like so so I
take lessons in tennis and I hit so if
you see me hitting if you see me hitting
I look alright I can hit I can mimic
it's kind of like watching somebody hit
mitts and there you go that guy can hit
mitts kenny box then I try to play Jimmy
a game my stroke is better and
everything then I try to play him he's
also got a fake hip he probably beat the
show you I tried playing he's better
athlete he's later he played sports his
whole life like he played basketball his
whole life he played he plays games so
he'll do things like this he'll he gets
in my head he'll go now I'm I'm not
gonna hit it to you the way you're used
to being hit - yeah so we're gonna lay
now yeah yeah so I'm gonna hit it so
he'll drop it he'll hit it shitty over
there and I lose every single time it's
just different same thing is you're your
trainer whether it's your box is trying
to go dude you could fight yeah baby of
course is the best or yeah or is there
if your your brain still say your
personal of course I might wait I'm
telling me I'll do that or your personal
trainer going dude you look you look
good man have you but you've lost weight
is like will bite entire cheese
I love it this is so a girl yeah I love
it it's the best doesn't Dustin said
that to Jimmy apparently Jimmy goes
Dawson looked it looked at me and he
goes pretty impressive I was doing low
kicks oh of course I mean of course of
course doesn't worry I said that he
wants it to be true
hilarious I'm not fooled that picture of
Eddie's that yeah let's head and watch
that for a second a bit but before was
funny God shot a double shitty double
but the guy just went back and does that
oh he's a great start on high school in
Delhi Ameer ready fetch it I am a sloth
who stumbled upon edibles even before
this was he's doing it's funny I know
he's amazing I get any round up not
route up but I like to go down the
conspiracy 30 hole with them not because
I'm mocking him or I think he's crazy
none of that Tanner tonight it's
entertaining but I genuinely want to
know how he came upon this theory or how
exactly what row did he go down to yeah
but like give me give me somethin ya
know like I want to know and because
I'll start checking and looking into it
myself right just to see what it's about
but it is interesting and even if it's
all malarkey and [ __ ] so interesting
I'm Sam you can take certain stuff from
and that might be some true facts
hey um yeah I mean it's it's it's it
he's got a logic to it there's a logic
that you can kind of follow there's a
huge yeah there's a whole movement of it
I'm looking at myself and it's reminding
me when my cousin came to my show in
West Palm Beach and he's a plastic
surgeon and this last week yeah that's
correct sir and Plastic Surgeons will
look at your face and I look at my what
I go he goes what I go you're a plastic
surgeon you're looking at my face I go
thene and I go now now my eyes
my eyes my mother's telling me that my
eyes I have inherited this they were and
our family the skin will cover your
[ __ ] eyeball I go oh you say he goes
he goes he goes I could take some that
skin off and I go but nobody can know
nobody can see it
anything goes no nobody's gonna see it I
go so you could lop off some of the skin
his wife's like yeah it look great and I
was like hmm go down to Florida come
back with new eyes new eyes new ass
wouldn't be little snip-snip of the nose
be my it can't be my age though and come
back with your eyes you'd be a little
you know but but I thought but there is
that skin that's I would know I would
yell on this podcast and let everybody
know if you're gonna get plastic surgery
on your face as a dude you have to talk
about it no or don't like you're doing
your eyes something you want to know
through I got calyx young I love it you
guys just came home singing off there
yeah he's your cousin
yeah plastic surgeon could hook you up
I'm sure yeah again I do die I can't
realize how I was hungover I woke outs
more like what tough [ __ ] dude oh my
eyes oh yeah bags on bags on bags
whiskey whiskey and weed you go
whiskey's what really gets you all the
wine too if you're not drinking over
five bottles of wine I'm glasses that
wine was good though wasn't it I start
drinking wine because my dad was helping
me move last week and he brought or know
my girl likes at menage-a-trois why yeah
for whatever reason I shot wha menage à
droite so we say we a correctly a menage
tois so we had six bottles of it so he's
had at the house yeah
jump in the hot tub sip on that I sleep
like a goddamn baby baby so I started
drinking wine then when you brought it
was like you might as well have some
classes with the press classes and then
the joint started going around like
might as well smoke this well you said
to me you go I'm be a gentleman and
bring some wine and you came through
dude I had to cheese - yeah nice try out
that cheese when anything else I was
like dinner the cheese you freaked out
over first was the manchego then you had
the Cypress the Cypress was the money
how about any muscle it puts in and
spits it out and I was the best cheese I
know you don't like nutty and sweet
you're like nothing you know morphic
cheese now under if there's a way to
make my face less long I wonder if my I
wonder if we can show you later
are from Lion King I do don't I have
that metal when you look at scar you're
slowly turning a villain yeah long big
years my nose keeps growing yeah I had
just keeps getting longer great did you
hate some each other time waits for
nobody
father time doesn't give a [ __ ] and the
idea is just to be an old guy it's all
good stay tight stay tight state here's
the thing stay limber
like a range of motion this guy was the
head coach of the national gymnastics
team who's been training gymnast for 40
years he also trained Special Forces
guys to a lot of these guys and he was
talking about the the biggest mistake is
that people will put on crazy amounts of
muscle and have no range of motion when
they're older just a flea to put a crazy
muscle like a lot of these soldiers
coming with 80 pounds of muscle and they
may have to arrange a monastery yeah I'm
also you have to work the connective
tissue connective tissue is different
than your main muscle area so you can
blast your your core but most people
train their connective tissue that's why
love like just so many digits you guys
so many like CrossFitters they just get
her because they're doing these big
movements without perfect technique and
you you're gonna [ __ ] yeah your
shoulders your neck you know all that
stuff if you're not the one thing they
do is they work on that [ __ ] and they'll
work on you if you're if you're starting
out with their program eight months of
like stuff that seems boring but you're
getting stronger and making progress and
then you you can you can last that
doesn't have to do gymnastics now it was
this thing this guy was talking about it
and it was really interesting I'm gonna
so I'm gonna become a gymnast just what
I'm saying I was wondering what the
payoff was oh yeah just a stretch no
dude I want to compete in gymnastic you
it bro
do it man I want to do it cat [ __ ] what
he has been up to
cat has some new Yeezys on I'm at I'm at
all I know my parents this weekend they
came back into town from from San Jose
oh that's right they're up north yes I
get my baby brother in San Jose
mm-hmm yeah a lot of enemies people a
lot of Filipino I love it up there
how was it with your parentals it's good
everything's good they're taking like
sightseeing and [ __ ] that's the worst no
my dad actually grew up in
Westminster before he moved to San Jose
yeah did they get a hotel they stay with
you no they stay with my grandparents of
grandparents in Orange County
yeah yeah just children ate and talked
basically they're worried I work too
much yeah you do work a shitload coming
from a refugee that says lot that's true
yeah I'm not a refugee but I appreciate
that one there's yeah it's there's
immigration and there's refugees yeah
big difference no joke
babe joke dear Franz yeah chin what'd
you do buddy uh not much not ton I made
a another YouTube video Oh singing no no
no do you we're not gonna watch it but
it's just me catching a fish and cooking
it and eating it where'd you catch the
fish at we need all right okay dude just
play me a clip if you catch a slash I
didn't there's no how can you solve
right there's no way follow you on
YouTube no you don't undo this I'm like
what kind of fish did you cut it this
weekend and killed it no no I cry
remember we talked about it all ago I
want fishing and then I finally uh oh
you just never get here together yeah
yeah 22 right well I don't wanna watch
the video but then it's just catching
some fish should be too long yeah a
minute yeah we're not gonna let me just
see the fish you catch on like those
[Music]
alright that's a lot of dudes on that
boat that's fishing so they're called
finish yeah no yeah you don't want to
get stung with the nine they're venomous
I think the spines are venomous spines
are you didn't eat those right you
thought I Jack why would you eat they're
delicious
yeah I'm surprised that they're not you
eat lionfish
I'm not lionfish that's all you got
scorpion line for the same thing that's
all you caught it yeah that's all they
had I guess that's the season right now
you catch them with your hands no
fishing pole
[ __ ] man 250 feet deep which is super so
when you fill your rod up or your your
reel up with line it's like you're at
the very last end of it when it's
halfway down there those boys are all
the way down there yeah hmm hmm but
they're delicious
are they yeah you cut them and kill them
yourself you got it on yourself
since they charge like a dollar each
fish just to gut it we just did that and
then took home like fillets took homer
the entire body but just no guts just
all sorts of different ways it's good no
guts no glory baby no guys no yeah well
this time you fished oh no unless my
fish was with my son off the pier my
daughter off the pier caught absolutely
nothing well I often Annika I hate
fishing you know that I respect that
people like it ia
hell I'd like that last time I went I
was with I was in Hawaii with least her
Bonin joke laughing Stein and we're on
this boat going around the island and
they were they were catching fish but
then like kinda kind of chumming the
water like there take it and the thing
to be bleeding they tossed in the water
like well we're snorkeling around here
yeah this is shark tiger sharks
this shark neighborhood yeah I went oh
let's get the [ __ ] out the water like no
you're fine brought you fine bromley
we're not fine why he uh why he has
tiger sharks wearing kawaii yeah why
before we got there the summer before
someone was murdered by a tiger shot oh
yeah and I was like I feel like this is
a bad idea at te lot looks like a giant
sea lion on steroids yeah Peter attea
who's this who's a doctor but a
long-distance swimmer I said I guess
didn't swim from quiet to lanai because
of the tiger sharks too many giant tiger
sharks they get your sharks not a
problem well that there you go that's
what that's what elite you and they know
you decide nothing will decide to take a
little chomp out of your ass or your leg
and humans man look at him for that
what's the best-case scenario there
that's a tiger shark just scared [ __ ]
that one's stupid those don't bite you
punch them in the [ __ ] snout the reef
shark piece of shits like he's a [ __ ] I
mean that's a tiger bobber
that's not tiger all the very sand tiger
shark those things are stupid yeah keith
is scary though real tiger the El Tigre
shark no bull sharks apparently are
worse holy [ __ ] he's putting that shark
in
tonic what's called tonic trying to flip
it over yeah so when you touch on snows
but tiger sharks family if you grab them
on either side of their head though they
go into tonic yeah if you're closer
though yeah I've seen it
oh my god I can't tell what's not I
think he's feeding it some sort of fish
I just don't get what it's equal to each
animal we're gonna size those teeth they
eat anything license plates yeah fingers
do yes yeah but they're not they're not
gonna attack humans usually that's weird
because more people get attacked by
tiger sharks than the other sharks bull
sharks have the Wreckers great whites
have the most fatalities I believe no no
all depends on those stats are he's
funny to me odds are you die in your car
yeah cuz I'm always in my car but if I
was always in the ocean every day my to
grow up way higher especially off
Waikiki that's right work Hawaii that's
right
oh really Aska who surfs every morning
what his odds are probably higher Paul
de Gelder said that what they think bit
his leg and hand off was a bull shark
good job big bull shark whoo Paul de
Gelder remember that guy we had who had
a fake hand and a fake leg oh yes yeah
he lost it to what they think was a
psalm in the airport you know when you
just since bowls are softened all and
very Shores are found in many types of
habitats including Lakes our territorial
by nature and have virtually no
tolerance for provocation they may be
more dangerous to humans than any others
because bulls can go fresh or salt along
with the tiger shark great whites are
among the three sharks that kill humans
I saw a boy who's attacked by the shark
at the airport
I didn't want it you know yeah I just
don't have the energy to catch up so I
pretend I didn't see him which guy Paul
yeah that's what happens in life you're
busy you're you've got [ __ ] on your mind
let's talk for a living so I do I don't
want to get attached yeah they did see
that that's what's gonna happen there's
not a lot to say it's only called me
over to another way cuz you're gonna say
hi and that's you know yeah yeah great
guy though you know no story
kill him Rick [ __ ] has to still do the
damn thing to hell so [ __ ] you surfing
Wow
God a nothing thing by a shark if you're
gonna lose it that's the way you want to
do it though right it's a badass story
yeah better than losing like a machine
he's awesome oh I'll get construction
worker go back to that is that a fake
that looks pretty real
Wow that's he's [ __ ] she acted jacked
yep yep mm-hmm he was on Shark Week for
a hot minute
usually other lead he kind of guys
SunTrust we yeah right yeah I don't see
how Shark Week keeps coming up with
original content every every [ __ ]
year at Shark Week and it's the same
[ __ ] over no like you only
yeah I mean how many times you gonna say
it's all the great white jumping out and
then they're like we've been falling a
shark for a you know few years though
that it's always the same [ __ ] I don't
see how they're gonna keep it going when
how the ratings are yeah because
nothing's i watch and like seen it I was
in there Tahiti and this this woman who
was a oceanographer studying you know
sea turtles and stuff and she had
crossed the Atlantic and the Pacific
many times in a sailboat in a sailboat
and she said one of the greatest things
she was coming her hair one night and
one morning and she saw this great white
for each the water and she was like [ __ ]
is it so incredible and then I said and
she goes yeah and I used to love to just
jump in the water I'd swim and I was
like what do you mean to go you know
when you in the middle of the ocean you
jump in you just swim around I go you're
not afraid of sharks she goes not at all
not even a little bit no she's crazy
well but she just no sharks and she
knows that they she was like people that
they're just not dead but when you're in
the middle of the ocean they're really
hungry sometimes there's no coral or
anything so they might grab you yeah you
have no idea what they're around well if
the Sharks like I'm [ __ ] starving
look at this idiot that jumped out of
their boat to swim around but I heard
that out there's nothing for the chance
yeah but I
out there there aren't as many fish when
you're in the middle of the ocean
because it's so deep I don't know but
I'm not getting in the water where I
can't see any land and that scares me
you know I said to the woman and went in
South African we were going to look for
great whites and I said you saw these
giant swells in the middle of the ocean
they were just like these big waves
would break I go this looks like a
surfers paradise she goes yeah but every
shark that you can imagine is here and
all the dangerous ones live right here
and you know when they say either no
sharks here but there are a lot over
there this is over there
she was this is where all of them are
Jews this is where if you want to see
great whites this is where they live
they're right here so the surfers don't
go and they surface did you guys see any
great white it's no surfers going there
because it's probably a matter of time
did you see any gray shirt didn't we
didn't sell bronze well he's full of Sh
no this is where you go for the great
white dives in South Africa problem was
you saw the two Orca the two Orca
brothers came and cleaned cleared out
Otis also worked us - I didn't see the
orcas either now let me finish
I did see Whalers [ __ ] nobody was all it
would be around but there's orcas for
the whole industry around that's where
you go to see great whites and the case
is already there oh yeah the kids are
there and you're soon as you start
chumming the water oh I'm sorry no
actually so you know why the great
whites come and okay because when they
hear the boat they go this food and they
just come like like the crocodiles in
Costa Rica they're like ah [ __ ] a boat
mm-hmm
chicken the crocodiles were [ __ ] lazy
though remember there's great whites
they know you're gonna come up and give
me food that's what they say the problem
with shark diving is is the Sharks us
they think okay bow cage in the water
I'm gonna get fed yeah so if they see
bow in the water humans swimming around
they think Oh food fed done that's right
look at that locomotive though look at
that giant locomotive
I would love to do that might have a
heart attack but I still want to do
before I die yeah me too real cuz you
don't go down in scuba gear it did the
caves there and you just get in there
with your snorkel and you go onto the
water no if you're scuba certified and
you want to do that yeah exactly that
looks super intense but yeah I guess I
do I cage looks way too wide for me I
need more of us
of mass yeah I need to have my cage on
land and I'll videotape I'll just watch
these dummies do it
see look at that bling that gayness
leave the [ __ ] shark don't put me in
the water and bring so that's what they
were doing and I was like those are
bronze whales I was like keep that [ __ ]
you don't give a [ __ ] about that shark
that [ __ ] I didn't get in the water my
nephews and my brother nothing real yeah
well that would be terrifying if that
happen
yeah probably didn't you think that's a
Photoshop but it's pretty cool see he
looks wrong you ever see when people put
a nice dark make some wet real friendly
kind of thing is terrifying though yeah
would we be as scared of them if a jobs
never came out be they just didn't need
humans no not at all do you think that
if Francis knew well now they because if
Francis and Ghana and I like so if
Francis and Ghana and I are walking
naked in the forest or in the water and
a lion comes along do you think the lion
goes I'm not gonna eat I'm gonna take
this skinny guy do you think the shark
goes deeper yeah you think the shark
goes I'm not gonna eat that guy looks
like he'd fight back I might eat or does
he go
mmm that guy's bigger and tastier no I
think they'd go freak it's the easy kill
you think so yeah
just like they do Angela yeah well just
like not going for the big also the
mountain lion goes for kids they don't
go like tigers go for kids so there is
so the I so I'm walking with Francis I'm
gone oh yeah I'm probably gonna be
dropping I'm lunch
yeah that makes sense I'm the weak link
you knew that answer no but I but again
now the great white man go you hasty
aren't you and Francis give me a goddamn
break but if you chilling cat do you
think you take your cat for a cat I
don't know she's cuter younger I'm I'm
old and gray and wrinkly this is why
there was crows it's gonna be easier
yeah but my old meat yeah yeah I mean
like would you rather eat an old bull
that's been sitting in a round table
dry-aged
that's true that's true it's not hard to
chew yeah we're talking about dry aged
steak last night so we're gonna stay
cast Jim Rohn see is a 320 day
yeah of course you're going the Xtra
never seen a restaurant 300 gusting
gross 320 day 8 dry aged steak I was
like that's a lot of that's a long time
look super suspect to the ones that are
hanging and stuff right but there's no
cold or you know though that's when they
cut off all the the mold and [ __ ] all
over it those are some black this is a
weird thing because just leaving it out
unless gross germs and bacteria well now
you're it's it's refrigerated cut it out
yeah breaks down the meat yeah that's
strange huh
it's tasty I should lack black meat it's
it's rotting yeah yes inside part of the
inside it is essentially rotting doesn't
mean it's not amazing that's rotting
it's kinda like cheese right it's kind
of like this doesn't say cheese you try
as cheese remember that that looks so
good right now does all this well I'll
leave that [ __ ] right now
oh well yeah yeah all wood dude I know
yeah you eat beef yeah let me know that
you're a pescetarian of some sort no I
will eat everything Chin's not a
pescetarian I love fish though like fish
I'm kind of over like shrimp and lobster
why I like lobster rolls I'm kind of
over crab and those the bugs of the sea
yeah okay she's hunting let's go back to
the fights if you raise Cain fights Cano
again do you put your money on gone oh I
don't know you're not gonna see it again
so don't you're not gonna see that I
know then why would they do together
yeah yeah Kane's deep bay if anything
maybe yeah who does who does Cano fight
now Francis would fight by the winner of
JDS and Derrick Lewis or there's a small
chance Brock Lesnar be a cool poster
Francis Brock Lesnar it's too freaky
freaks
yeah I feel Francis I feel Francis beats
Derek Louis they fought before right and
Derek beetle that's right that's right
when was that not that long ago man
Francis him
there was an awful fight yeah I forgot
about that yeah I can't do man
how about Cain was talking about he
didn't get hit he goes I didn't get
touched my knee just gave out mmm-hmm so
he said what does that mean he did get
hit
not according to him well what he what
did what he got he says he got that that
uppercut and his shovel shucks how many
fell that's what that's what brought him
to his knees that's what that's what
made him fall he got hit he fell and
then he turned his knee out that's what
happened I know dude I don't think it
knocked him out cuz he the pain was like
ah you know then he was definitely knock
them unconscious for a second that's
what I felt oh that's right yeah that's
me Flash Player yeah and then he gave up
but it was the punch that touches well
he lost his body to shut off this place
he went
correct a tweet we now what do you say
about his name anything there's no up
there's no updates on how he's doing
right now I got a nice carrot juice man
his body is just just is one of those
bodies that just is canes yeah it's just
it looks it looks so soft you know so
high last night I think I called him a
gordita crunch so I sold I didn't hear
that
I wish you guys would stop me man suffer
gross online ordering Frances no I
couldn't stop you
yeah man be like dude come on bro but by
the time you say it I can't take it back
it's already out there you could say hey
let's let's take you down a notch no
they go okay Chuck you take a better
sheriffing no nothing there's nothing
new right I hope isn't he isn't too bad
I want to see him fight again I want to
I was a bummer
you guys alright nice [ __ ] carrot
juice man you know delicious Kron Gracie
what's your what your what's your take
on Kron as far as his future in the UFC
it's tough man well well here's my
question I feel like he is he is he the
cubby before the 45 no no you guys what
I mean I mean he stopped as snooze could
be grabs you know takes down you're in
trouble as soon as he takes you down
you're in trouble because khabib is a
world elite class wrestler Kron is not a
wrestler he's a crab but what I'm saying
is that what I'm saying is that if kabhi
we know if kabhi grabs you now you're in
a world of trouble now it's a matter of
time get you down yes yeah
if good world is like a submitter knock
you out
most of almost all that he does about
you there yeah right exactly what I'm
saying is you're gonna lose you're gonna
wear he's like it's gonna be a year
backpack for the next 25 minutes it's
gonna suck
chrome is different because if he gets
you and you go to the ground with him
you're gonna get tapped yeah it's a
matter of time right hmm so and to me
it's like what's your question you only
way to stop him is to knock him out
before he closes distance if he closes
distance there's a lot of us you can do
that though Greg a lot of guys who won't
get taken down and just yeah yeah like
his striking you know it's gonna be his
hole that's gonna be him figure that out
yeah but I feel like anybody who's that
good at closing distance well Amy and
Maya but he got stopped you get so
there's been just two guys before yeah
this isn't new yeah you talk about a
Gracie in the UFC
yeah I mean Crona at 45 you know he is
the he's kind of the protégée you know
he's the [ __ ] man yeah he's gonna
figure it out it's gonna be a lot of
guys I don't know if they thoughts on my
top five right away but as good as good
as you Jitsu as anybody that's ever
stepped into the Octagon correct it's up
there or better it's good it says he's
Gracie yeah what's your question bro my
question is that that was interesting
when he took that what's-his-name's back
there's a mid-level fighter yeah
misters first fight in the UFC let's see
where it goes man yeah
yeah bring him up slowly yeah school
some current events dude here we go oh
wait hold on let's do this first
oh ah [ __ ] guy dude yeah so after
some thorough investigation police have
figured out who the two men in the
original photo that was released are and
there are two Nigerian guys that they
let that allegedly Jesse hired for I
think it was thirty five hundred dollars
so he can so they could stage this
attack they actually went and
investigated their apartment and found
that they had a bunch of magazines open
and like cutout so they weren't able to
confirm that the note that was sent to
Jesse a few weeks before the attack was
from them but there were tons of
magazines everywhere this guy's socks
and shitty guys yeah and when the police
officers told Jesse hey we found the
guys Jesse said I want to press charges
and then when he found out who the guys
were in there - I think like actors
they're friends yeah they're like oh the
Empire with him yeah they're like these
two really really like a jacked Nigerian
dudes he he saw a photo of who the
attackers were and he said that he
didn't want to press charges anymore and
now he is actually under investigation
himself for making these claims and he
has a hearing next oh yeah he's gonna be
prosecuted and what if what is there guy
well well what's been so embarrassing
will the court go all right your career
is completely over yeah we'll give you
parole yeah it's not that it's not the
sense it's that you're done you're a
fraud and what's interesting about guys
like this is so you're a singer and
you're an actor and a good one from what
I hear you know you you don't know
anything about crime and you decided to
try to pull a crime off with do to study
crime and you thought you could cover
your bases by hiring two actors you
didn't know they wrote that letter of
course they have their [ __ ] lying around
because they're not expertise they spend
on
I'm lifting weight this aprama be their
friends and their friends so it's easy
to so you can make a connection had a
relationship before yeah I what
and you thought that that would be a new
thought you thought you were smarter
than the Chicago Police for this career
suicide a do and a couple of days before
they found out that all those magazines
were lying around and that those two
guys were his friends when they are
arrested those two men for questioning
he lawyered up and hired Michael Cohen's
former lawyer yeah before any of this
came to watch him go and I fought back
member that he's no great don't do the
bring up the interview with him and
Robin from Good Morning America this is
it this is it it's so this is on this is
we gotta watch this this is simply grew
in two weeks and there very few leaves
leading many to have questions about
that night why did you hesitate to call
the police it's so awkward out there we
live in a society where as a gay man you
were considered somehow to be weak and
I'm not weak I'm not weak any other
people are not weak he's good man good
actor I saw the bruise on my leg you
know like the little the ropeburn around
my neck bleach and I saw on my sweater
it had marks I don't think she believes
in me there we go now it's all job so
then I was like there's bleach army to
house so create the clothes on so you
had the rope on the entire tonight I
wasn't like a wrap the Rastas show at it
was around I told them what happened
everything I also asked them to turn
their body cams off cuz they were trying
to stay rich in a hallway I was like
please just come in you're robbing she's
on me with my neighbors and with like
this session it feels like get ready if
I had say Oscar it was a Muslim or
Mexican or someone black I feel like the
doubters would have supported me a lot
much more a lot more his phone he's
being massaged wondering why he didn't
initially hand it over to authorities
I'm sorry can i but he's a bad guy and
he sees me won't do that small that what
you see
see smollett private to cooperate he
really the outsmart he did that because
he's an arrogant too little prick and a
liar says he has been troubled by
inaccurate claims this is so hard and
watch I'm so embarrassed I said that
sneakily
we're wearing Magga hats I've never said
that I didn't need to add anything like
that they called me up they called me
there's no which way you cut it I don't
need some do you could have sold dude
this is so bad I heard that it was a
date gone bad which I so resent that now
I can't watch this take it off I can't
handle it all you missed the bass player
girl no I can't watch her music Robin
it's so bad man all these people can't
see you and yet you got caught he's all
I don't know how you I don't know what I
would do I think I would have to like I
would move you at the mob but you can't
make a living anymore and nobody wants
you
I would become simple Jack in Dubai what
would you not go anywhere
hi this is this is the worst but here's
the problem obviously his career is
[ __ ] whatever he did to himself like I
don't like it I don't like destruction
for [ __ ] I don't like seeing I
don't want to be bright I don't have a
lot of sin because he was trying to
[ __ ] create this really like but he
was trying to be so device here's the
problem the problem is now when someone
actually has a hate crime and they're
beat up for being gay or black or Asian
or Muslim right and now they come to
authorities now the society rolls its
eyes because this dummy right did this
stuff right and you're in now and so and
actually hasn't really know of other
people's real like and for what it took
for a it's not pursue here it's to make
his career it's like being a war
profiteer you know how people like to
say I was there I got shot at okay then
you rise you you weren't even you know
you didn't have any ammo and your gun
whatever it is but least during the race
least you in the military yeah this
homeboy is was onset these characters
getting written off because I just come
up with something let's take advantage
of me being a gay black man yeah and
Trump I also think he was trying to be
sort of
a voice have enough voice yes yes yes
yes I really do you know it's money
Colin Kaepernick's made for doing all
this yeah but he didn't know he didn't
know when he did it didn't know when he
when he actually kneeled you know he
just he was taking a stand and he
kneeled and yeah wasn't us which was his
right as an American for sure you know
paid a price for it but well I think he
had I think he had balls cuz he didn't
know he's gonna make millions of dollars
then I'm not I think he just was trying
to make a stand right I mean you might
be more cynical about it but mmm dude
though this guy is well I'm not say
that's the bad guy he just was
opportunists that's what the opportunist
he's a liar and it's not solid or what I
just and I we get people been for the
doubt probably can't let that [ __ ]
have oh man
the news getting rid off your show yeah
it's more that I believe is we as human
beings know when somebody is we have a
feeling because you know we can you
don't wait too many interviews yeah my
mother my mother always says we
communicated as human beings way before
we had language and we learned how to
read people's body and read how they you
know just how they come at you what
their eyes are saying what their body is
saying before they say and you can tell
when somebody's a liar you really can
you can see it you can go you can just
do something about it's like Joe Rogan
talked about a guy one time who was gay
who was pretending to be straight all
the time and Joe said he described him
perfectly he goes he sounds like a guy
who doesn't speak French trying to
trying to speak French like he sounds
like he's like oh don't want a donut
okay it's like oh you actually sounds
like it's true well you do relate two
minutes left I got let me just finish my
eyes so he it's so serious it's the best
I'm in Paris yeah we have the right and
responsibility to make something mean
sisters pretty hot I think she is good
she's from like a old TV show she's from
Hanna's first time that he's getting
such a detailed account and he was I was
really excited when he saw let's go back
here wait she said he was really excited
for what the message for them and how
they are viewing how this is being
handled but he was
pretty forthcoming first was to say
thank you to his many supporters to
answer the question if you want a PR
tour about a hate crime
you went awesome you saw that I came
emotional and straight up here I've
never heard of the guy till this happen
then you go on the straight up PR tour I
it's so fishy dude it's embarrassed how
about the director of the show going he
called me this happened when he
supportive so all these people brought
their support out and now he just the
show is getting a lot of backlash too so
the writers had to come out and say
there was absolutely no nothing proving
that we were gonna write him off he's
the third lead like we weren't gonna
write him off and I don't know whether
it's them covering their ass because
they're getting backlash like did you
guys set this up so you guys could get
more promotion for Empire cuz ratings
have gone down the guy who's he would
squeal if that was that point his
careers over he go the writers told me
to do this and then yeah the guy the guy
who the guy who did this might be there
might be his agent it might be in
trouble if his agent is you know he
called his agent before it happened
so his agent could be a little bit of
heat too if he cooperated with this
again do this this but you know who's
gonna get to the bottom of it the
detectives in Chicago PD well because
they they're well they're very bottom of
it yeah kind of all bottom because
they're professionals
it's exactly like getting in the ring
with somebody's been fighting a long
time you want to pull off what oh that
left hook against that guy oh yeah but
he's seen that a thousand times
oh yeah remember that when Lee Daniels
is all say message play then even he has
that same kind of like all kind of I
don't trust this guy either at all it's
taken me a minute to come to social
media about this because Jesse you are
my son I think they're both deserve
higher
you know anybody deserves to have a news
put around your neck to have bleach
thrown on you to be called dye or
whatever they said to you
Virtue's signaling here we go you are
better than that we are we are better
than that America is better than make
there's better than your friends piece
of [ __ ] it starts at home yo we have to
love each other regardless of what
sexual orientation we are because it
shows that we are united on united front
and nobody says this and come in and do
the things that they did to you he's
right I mean I like it that's enough
mercy I'm with you I'll be there in a
minute
it's just another day in America they're
just pushing that that narratives all
right again it's like if you did
something tell me did that to you I'm
talking to you I'm not going on social
media necessarily I mean I see see if
there was that like you tell me don't
don't do that weird general message that
everybody could snow thanks for that I
know I didn't know any of that you know
thanks for the support
it's it's everybody travel on sixteen
hours ago
Jesse small it gets renewed support from
Empire showrunner hit that dude I
believe and stand by Jesse smaller keep
your head up okay Bret get your head out
of your ass okay then you figure out his
team trying to scramble right now trying
to figure it out are they scrambling or
no this was a while ago wasn't it man
what oh this is recently yeah this is
that's why I brought it up all right
you think you're steamed scrambling to
try and figure out what to do well you
know this is the end of your in a way
how do you spin it so you don't have a
job what are you gonna do not just his
job but just everything his life his
family his friends everyone so how do
you nurse go to assist I wouldn't be
worried about him you know you want
something really drastic I don't know
really know what what is some a
narcissist to kill himself yeah right
that one yeah meet her should figure it
out yeah you till the bottom was she
what's her nationality I think she's an
angel right
yeah I think they're like part white
what is what movie she's a she
originally started in full house dude
you're right what else was she in there
you go she's super pretty well she also
full of [ __ ] like her brother or no I
don't know I don't want to I don't want
to do any guilt by association she might
be a great person that was probably yeah
sorry sorry but I'm oh I was just kinda
kid I got a little breasts on what the
whole assume brendan job I think she's a
good person
yeah Brian damn she's been in a bunch of
stuff Friday Night Lights that's a long
that's a long country I think what I
remember from Grey's Anatomy [ __ ]
robots nope
I shouldn't working for a hobby yeah oh
yeah she's a child actor dude Eve's
Bayou damn remember that
mmm Martin hey mr. Cooper there it is
hanging mr. Cooper
shout out to hang on mr. Cooper what
else you guys not man that guy can you
imagine waking up being him like what
the [ __ ] am I gonna he's gonna be
prosecuted and the only chance he has
the only chance he has is to figure out
a way to say that is to get a small
subset of people to believe that this
that the Chicago EDR races what they're
talking about yeah yeah saw that like
the only way is that that nobody wanted
to believe it it was a cover-up and he's
telling the truth if your only chance is
for the ladies gonna be like five
Hollywood and everybody to put on their
blinders like they do and pretend that
this all was legit and that the Chicago
PD is on her oh come on
and that this really highly Perry even
though we have the two-seven Nigerian
guys even though we have all the
evidence you'll see or the Nigerian guys
like nah man we definitely did this you
know you need everybody cooperate that's
probably what they're trying to go now
oh you don't think that's gonna happen
Oh happening oh the Nigerian guys are
gonna sing like couple canary there you
have like couple must work it out
I'm in custody they see an hour they let
him go they like we got it yeah yeah
under protection for the Chicago PD
right now yes or nobody from justice
yeah they're holding them drop and rock
studied lasted three men because they're
the black here's a million dollars so he
doesn't have that money I guarantee it
but he's give him whatever he has to but
no no no now this equipment all damn
they can't get to him it's old and
everyone of course the cops driving that
be driving and tamper and gather and
come up with a new store that cops like
no no of course you're here oh no it's
it's you guys are off-limits we're in
deal with this dummy videotaped in and
and and probably a matter of record are
you forced a confession out of us no
we'll just stay there and we'll just get
you up on the stand and now we'll see if
you and and if you read out some pros if
you want to give them money it's called
tampering with a witness it's all no
dude they're so far sir this is a this
is a this is a criminal prosecution you
rest you Wes yeah Chicago PD a very
mixed to term drop police force not just
to I felt like I don't know I said then
it felt comfortable that I understand
what else we got well what would you do
if that was your friend would you still
be friends with them I believe that none
of my friends not all my friends by now
yeah do that we wouldn't be friends
we've all we've all told lies right so
we've all done things but that that is a
staging that's a character flaw going
public with it it's like a domestic
you'll be using your gayness your
blackness whatever it is you do using
your vulnerabilities to further divide
this country and prey on people really
crammed people further divide this
country create more division more hatred
not not bringing bees not bringing
people together here he's what he's
doing is he's putting the gap even
further that's right cuz people go look
at me I told you guys the people who
want to believe that this is how they
act is going look at these [ __ ] I
told you man
that's right I've told you this what
they dad that's not the tray you go now
you got that that's that's right so he's
made it yeah he's made it worse in every
category he tried to divide that way and
now he's made it even though he's hurt
because who are already yeah and people
are already
biggest Frenzel bigoted or what happens
to are now gonna be like told you see
what they do yeah exactly think of his
family they're pretty well they were all
came out we're like we stick by in there
probably god damn yeah it's just like
what the [ __ ] dude look man that this is
the kind of thing this guy is this guy
has done nothing good here I've done
nothing because this isn't the first
time he's done some [ __ ] like we
just don't do like that but he's done
some shady [ __ ] I get where he's at
people like this are all this isn't a
one-time carries a track record yeah I
don't like seeing destruction I don't
like if I was just reading outside my
dick pic and go suck yeah yeah I don't
suck I don't like seeing anybody me my
friends got together that's what we keep
this is this is this is destruction
right this is what when this all comes
out I feel like he's destroyed right and
I don't like seeing that friend I don't
want him to be I like seeing a child
molester something like that that's fine
but like someone like this is an [ __ ]
a narcissist and all that but he
shouldn't be he is going to Thailand I'm
he is I'm not happy I don't like seeing
this
even with an [ __ ] like that I bring
him over to show what's gonna happen
I'll bring him on the show me and laugh
at him yeah yeah so there yeah they have
there but we called it didn't we yeah
feel like we're the first kind of sniff
that out our noses out and we were just
looking for evidence what else we got so
Dave Chappelle found out that there was
a couple glass cam two out of five
hundred dollars from a bad Craigslist
deal that was trying to sell two tickets
to his Valentine's Day show in North
Carolina and what happened was he
actually set up a meeting and gave them
tickets to his show
oh that's cool good man and for some
reason there were news reporters there I
don't know Dave but I've seen him but
he's such a good guy like I don't know
him but I I've seen him personally like
right there just like at the Comedy
Store he's just good to everybody he's
very gracious and very very humble dude
yeah really good guy this is a clipper
Love has his own Chappell line
his worries on shirt
these facilities where's his own [ __ ]
hmm that's cool what else so a show in
San Francisco had a medical emergency
and will end up happening was somebody
had a heart attack there I believe it
was their defibrillator set off a noise
and someone thought it was like a either
a gunshot or somebody something was
happening and people just assumed it was
a shooter and so everybody in the show
got up started running out people who
were performing Hamilton ran offstage
and in the process one person broke
their leg two other people had some
minor injuries yeah they end up getting
trampled but after I think it was about
half an hour an hour police and
firefighters came told everybody like
hey it wasn't a shooter it was some guy
who had a heart attack
we're all good dude me and my friend ran
over what a musical a Broadway musical a
long time ago those cats and the [ __ ]
they just did this guy passed out
fainted and had a heart attack
they carried him out in the stretcher
right there died and then nobody even
they were like whatever it was yeah we
were laughing so hard then well that was
like that did you see it the airport I
think it was I have in San Francisco to
where that crazy dude tried going
through security wouldn't stop and so
they thought he had a grenade or gun in
his hand so I have you see there's video
people like freaking the [ __ ] out and
running and there's dad's grabbing their
kids and jumping over the counter at
chick-fil-a and like it's mayhem but the
guy was just crazy we're all here
everyone thinks the worst now I'd
[ __ ] run out of that place too if I
thought it was I mean you know what we
are an employee because we know what the
possibility by the way by the way sososo
gun rights okay III own guns so I'm I
get it Second Amendment I got you and
but here's the thing we want guns to
protect ourselves and everything else
we are at a point where my friend Andy
Andy stumped SEAL Team six [ __ ]
his son high school son because how do
you like to school there in Montana son
goes I like it it's just the cafeteria
is so open he goes what do you mean he
goes I just you know somebody can come
in and start shooting all of us and
that's how all of us as Americans are
starting to feel like we're all kind of
feeling like anytime I go to the mall on
time I go to a public fair I'm always
kind of it's always in my head that some
other part could open up and start
shooting so I I do think we're at a
point in some ways in this country where
mass shootings are a complete [ __ ]
reality and nobody's doing anything
about it what do we do about nothing so
whatever it did the IRA I mean the IRA
the IRA the NRA goes the only way to
stop a good guy with a gun as a bad guy
with a gun I mean a good bad guy with a
gun is a good guy with a gun but they
never really have any answers so okay my
kid just got shot now what can you give
me something else is there is there a
way to solve this problem
I know pools and alcohol kill more
people I know that I know there's a very
intelligent argument for why people
should have guns again I own guns but as
soon as you come up with any solution
you're considered a [ __ ] [ __ ] or a
left winger that no I would just like to
know because right now my in my liberty
I believe in liberty my liberties are
being a little bit infringed on because
I'm always [ __ ] nervous that
somebody's gonna open up and that's a
reality so does anybody on that side
who's a second Amendment nut have an
answer I think their answer is everybody
should be able to carry a gun that's not
terrible but like I get the logic behind
that too maybe that's the answer
maybe you just say you can carry a gun
now homicides are gonna go way up cuz
people are gonna fight
I would imagine but then again there's
there's evidence says that's not even
true but is that the answer is that what
I get I don't know I don't know the
answer what about I do think if
somebody's mentally ill and they open up
with a gun it would be nice to have a
bunch of other people with guns who can
take them out but I talked to people who
really know this [ __ ] first responders
soldiers and they're like yeah then you
get shot by the cops you're put you got
your
the cops come into active shooter scene
they don't know who the [ __ ] is he'll so
what do you do be I don't know there's
here's an idea here's an idea is it is
it far-fetched and would it make a
difference if as an American you want to
buy a gun at least you got to go through
a safety course a test the way you do
with your car what why would that be bad
well that's what they do no no they
don't you have a background check you
get the gun I've bought three guns let
me have two guns ought to go through
it's just a it's just a background check
hmm you wait ten days and you're on Tori
but I went through a safety yeah it's
not mandatory but but and I don't know
also that course okay yeah still not
that huh how about 1500 makes a
difference fifteen I also like driving
school doesn't really happy yeah it's
fifty nine kids a year shot accidentally
by guns an ounce because seventy percent
of gun owners don't own safe yeah put
your gun is safe did certain things that
have just seemed like safety issues that
you know kids come across a pistol I
like bang so I don't know man I don't
and I don't know the answer but tell you
what you and I aren't gonna figure it
out here no we're not solving gum gun
control what else you got chin hmm well
real quick on that so you know you guys
have guns yeah my dad is a huge gun
collector my brother's a huge gun
collector I've never never wanted to own
a gun or never had interest in a gun
yeah even for protection I feel like
it's dangerous yeah well you should
leave my country but the Koreans are no
joke if I have no snowsuit it's not
surprising me your dad and your brother
are guns yeah alright Oh our Kelly is
back in the news because somebody on his
team hired a lawyer and gave him it's
the lawyer who defended stormy Daniels
and they turned over a VHS tape of our
Kelly back in the day with a 14 year old
girl and everyone's killed
yeah strand [ __ ] and the statue of
limitations within Chicago is it up yet
and so they're trying to take them to
court holy [ __ ] well in the video
apparently you can hear them saying over
and over look at that 14 year old and
then like a body part it's more than one
guy
no it's our Kelly and then it's a girl
who's clearly very young and over and
over in the video they keep on
reiterating her age it's a sexual
predator and he said yeah as a child
molester and then like at the end it has
a signature where he pees on her oh
there is that I thought that was already
out no this is another girl send a new
video B yeah he's a [ __ ] like like
come on go to jail yeah this that's what
they do so Jeff Jesse Smollett Emma this
guy's worse oh yeah just she's something
small that shouldn't go to prison no
this guy she's got a jet is his dudes
gonna be his cruiser yeah his socially
he's dead he's [ __ ] fine that's what
this guy said this guy's a predator yeah
he does this to chills he needs to be
bunked up with Cosby this should be
right next I mean maybe worse
no yeah yeah definitely but this is a
trial shitty yeah they're both like you
do grow pause him daddy several times
and they both are heard referring to her
genitals as fourteen-year-old [ __ ] the
man in the video also asked the girl to
urinate and when she's done hearing
that's on her what's up with this
pissing I'm marking her that's gross oh
my god well I heard that he had done
this the first time I was like well he's
done well how did he get off did he pay
her off or what happened the girl and
her family kept on denying that it was
her in the video and they wouldn't press
charges well that makes sense cuz they
don't want it and that was I think one
of the few videos that they were able to
arrest him on but since nobody would
come forward claiming that they were the
girl he had such as young as 13 years
old [ __ ] that guy bad parents do though
hey [ __ ] that guy and yeah and he's and
also he's a star he's older so he would
he would hypnotize them he would
basically have them say to help their
careers yeah and they're probably don't
have a lot of money or whatever they are
in their studio time young kid their
children their children so that's very
very easy for a manipulative sociopath
to do so [ __ ] r.kelly how about that in
Sony so where we where I shoot my show I
didn't see this but some of the people
told me that there was a somebody had
got a
Wayne and they were flying they were
circling Sony because I guess they have
they own his music right huh they said
shut down the sexual predator are Kelly
they were dragging a banner behind me oh
yeah they're protesting everywhere yeah
it's a studio all sorts of [ __ ] yeah go
ahead and go ahead and offer yourself
yeah bad dude
yeah what us yet um this era Brian Bob
Shaw book bombshell book alleges a
vatican gay subculture now is this
conspiracy theory I don't know so this
guy lived in the Vatican he's gay he
lived in the Vatican for three years he
interviewed thousands of Cardinals
bishops and priests thousands not
hundreds but thousands this took him
over three years he's a very
well-respected journalist in France so
it's about them live in double lives
yeah and what he found was that the
Vatican has not only is almost all gay
men a lot of those priests are all gay
including the Pope who's the king of the
Queens but this Pope is pretty cool
because this Pope is like basically
willing to he'd just be judged they just
[ __ ] got a cardinal sanction the
Cardinal Cardinal which has never been
done in the history of the church
apparently is the Pope's treat conducted
nearly 1500 in-person interviews with 41
Cardinals 52 bishops Monsignors and 45
Vatican and foreign ambassadors many of
whom are quoted at length and in in on
the record interviews that he says were
recorded he was assisted by 80
researchers translators fixers and local
journalists as well as a team of 15
lawyers and the the five hundred
fifty-five page book is being published
simultaneous in eight languages so what
they found is this that the number of
gay men is overwhelming and there's kind
of visible there's always been this this
war in within the Vatican between child
pedophiles people who join the
priesthood because they can hide behind
the cloth end and sexually rape children
and gay men and the gay men don't want
to out the pedophiles because the
pedophiles were then out of the gay men
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
shame
so the reason that paedophiles has been
allowed cuz nobody gives a [ __ ] if
you're priestess I don't care if the
proof there happened having sex and I
don't care about that if your men and
you're gay but obviously nobody wants
pedophiles being protected by the
Vatican which they have been and and
there's so much overwhelming evidence
but so that's what happened is that they
have you know do their thing so removing
that he wants to remove the secret
surrounds homosexual under church church
doctrine holds that gays are to be
treated with respect and dignity but the
homosexual acts are intrinsically
disordered francis knows that he has to
move opposed pope francis knows he has
to move the the Church's stance and only
be able to do it at the cost of a
ruthless battle against all those who
use sexual morality and homophobia to
conceal their own hypocrisy Zinn double
lives but there's this he talks about
this this war between the pedophiles and
the regular ones yeah but could be
matters like kind of God yes since many
prelates and positions of authority have
their own hidden sexual skeletons they
have no interest in dancing the criminal
pedophiles in their midst
lest their own secrets be revealed there
are many gay priests bishops Cardinals
of the Ministry today in the church but
most of them are like the straight
counterparts remaining faithful to the
life of chastity on syllabus yeah yeah
but but they just you know but if they
come go bad on the pedophiles in their
mist you know it could be a really
interesting book how I love this Martell
said um monster damn I tell the
traffic's in some of the worst gay
stereotypes by using sarcasm drivers
terms such as when he writes a Francis
despite Francis is to be is to be among
the wolves it's not quite sure he's
among the Queen's so I guess Francis
might be also gay I don't know
interesting man
yeah it's nothing we didn't know but I
thought that was new be good defense
that was new to me where I was like why
are they protecting these pedophiles
well elites they don't want their own
sexual skeletons pulled out of the
closet in the books out already but if
you're a man God know if you're a man of
God you should you should be like [ __ ]
myself
I'm way less important than the fact
that these children have been
Akio me [ __ ] right think and kill
those people
yeah what else get Jin your boy Russell
Peters you helped take down a jewelry
thief what jewelry thief ruff
Russell I cracked jokes and arms he
doesn't he does a lot of jiu-jitsu
mm-hmm ooh I see the video yeah so the
guy didn't wasn't like armed anything we
just try to run out of a jewelry store
in New York City that doesn't look like
Russell it is him
if this video plays Sex in the City
that [ __ ] still doing it oh no it's
Russell that's the thief no that's
Russell no in the red hoodie the thief's
in the black kid yeah or in the bad guy
out beanie rush was just looking through
some jewelry by a chain for himself for
his lady mm-hmm
so now the guy walks up with the jewelry
and then Russell sees it now he helps
Russell he got him Ozzy I'm Russ the
gives me he puts him in that arm walk
whoever works there's two at work though
- oh damn you got a minute
Larry almost you're funny Fred Oh Oh God
he's doing now oh he's just controlling
his arm yeah it's all good just so he
can't hit the guys I'm so strong that
was pretty tough
Russell strong guy I love Russell the
best and he didn't have to get involved
so it's pretty crazy ah smells like
gonna get got I'm 22 starts beating the
[ __ ] I'm is not gone why he will have
learnt the big guy do anything older all
right carry on shoutout to Russell
Peters yeah all right
this is not a big deal but Takashi six
nine I guess you might get like a huge
would he call it like they're gonna chop
down his sentence yeah like a big one
because he's gonna much rat
yeah fried out of everyone you gotta be
in that witness protection like any
concerts you do or anything it can't
that must be a root weird life celebrity
kind of easy to spot with your face
completely painted generally go back to
yours in the hood anymore right they
can't go back to me that stuff are you
gonna friends were you gonna see the guy
the guys the guys they snitching on it
so that's he was facing a minimum forty
seven years in prison minimum he ordered
yeah he was responsible for ordering a
murder oh yeah Oh tray ways no joke the
business that he's working for tray way
trouble so so he's a snitch this hard to
you know I guess still number of years
maybe in the teens but maybe even less
so maybe even like nine years
damn he's looking at a long time yeah
still gonna look for he's probably still
gonna look at a major time [ __ ] man 9
years 11 max musicality 7 but if he
snitched on everyone there you like 10
what they said in that a man in here now
you're over ten years so crazy that he's
but you gotta mean happen custody - yeah
gets a population that sucks
that's a long time in jail for tough gig
man yeah alright so yards already know
about the story but the guy finally
spoke up do you want to hear about his
attack with the who scratches worse his
remind you might be yours is a little
bit worse we did heal up a little bit I
mean yes other story though right yeah
much I ended up hearing some pine
needles rustle like a stick break and I
just the Jesse Smollett the [ __ ] mind
this was pretty bummed out to see a
mountain lion chasing after me scratched
out in my nether regions and oh dude got
his dick picked up a rock that I that I
had seen kind of near s
I love this guy's I mean it's kind of
hard to wield
and I charismatic try to give it a few
bashes and and so I hit it and the back
of the head that it didn't release that
it was a starving baby mountain grass
that's what happened yeah you murdered
that mountain lunch shift my waiver your
murder get a foot on its neck and then
you crushed it [ __ ] here win it on
its neck with my my right foot slowly
after a few minutes Toit I'd say another
couple of minutes later it finally
finally stopped moving and then jaws
opened and I was able to kind of
scramble back up the hill and get the
heck out of Dodge there you go we just
got an update on the Jesse Smollett
story Oh what happened
love come we shall see if it goes the
opposite way it's like they actually
found the guys he's not Oh God
oh Jesus find the guys it's a bad bad
situation but what a hopefully just
keeps going back and forth
Oprah comes to his defense puts him in
her first movie boom rehearsed attack
with the - oh my god it's gone force
first attack with two blasts had to do a
run-through dude and it still didn't
work rehearse the attack Genson is that
the runs - video was all staged for the
camera they got in my car was Jesse and
scouted location select in the one run
on the one right outside the actors
apartment your brother said Jesse chose
a spot because he believed a camera
would have captured it ooh that's what
he thought was gonna happen our source
said the brothers told the police Jesse
said he wanted to make it a physical
thing but not the point
oh wait he's seriously injured can I ask
a question hold on on the night Jesse
says he was attacked the brothers
claimed they showed up at the scene but
were extremely nervous because just as
they played out the scene a car drove by
in they're worried they'd be ID'd our
sources say the brothers performed per
the rehearsal they screamed out they
recognized Jesse from the Empire then
hurled a racist n-word and the
homophobic f-word the brothers told the
cops they made contact with Jesse's face
but it was weak they said they didn't
know how he suffered the bruises
but that this the stage fight was not
designed to injure him okay so so I'm
guys hold on but here's the thing I saw
them like in a different pose luck with
your giant here's the thing why can I
ask you this do the brothers you were on
a train oh but it was a race it was
racist attack so why did he have two
black guys to it well no because he
wouldn't you can't tell if they're black
or white yeah cause if he won't see
masks
that's so hello and because these are
only two guys that he knows oh my god
dude see you [ __ ] face these guys what
happened to those two though they just
say Mary's naked I just let them go
all right they're like you're good this
guy's a thirty five hundred bucks they
get off dude rehearsals that's that I
can't wait for more details to come out
when they I can't wait till he has to do
a sit when these guys have to find a job
now they're gonna have a tough time to
these two when you do a background these
two will be fine yeah no well there's no
charges are pressed yeah that's true but
there's two were fine no these two are
like nah we're trying help our friend
out whose career was not going well
trying to be solid pals and he [ __ ]
everything up Wow yeah well it's so
embarrassing you were gonna hire two
brothers for $3,500 and that this
wouldn't be some big thing did you think
you were gonna get away with it
oh [ __ ] he must be what else is where
does he thought that camera was not
gonna be facing north and was gonna film
this and then that evidence would just
help them out because they'd be on the
trail of two white guys not to Nigerian
friends of his I mean and they were also
on the show like you can you're so
dumped
he's actually just dumbest [ __ ] your
dumbest [ __ ] to think you could get away
with it this is an arrogant narcissist
I mean how do you - um you know that one
comedian guy I'm pretty sure you guys
know him but he's that guy right - yeah
9/11 like in this is way different but
mm-hmm okay they're right I think that
Steve kind of caught caught in a lie and
then went down a hole II couldn't get
out went out a hole cuz they immediately
he was new and somebody goes this is the
911 guy he just never yeah brought it up
again but then it kind of like brought
on a life of its own then he was on
Marin Marin asked about it means I got
[ __ ] and he said it I think that's what
kind of would just ease into though that
he had to continue hired rehearsed and
staged this Steve was just wanting
somebody to like him he's a comic he
kind of just said something off the cuff
cuz it sounded like a game tragedy guy
he got some prestige for it in the
moment he was like I'll [ __ ] I should
just think about this but he didn't let
me came out and finally said hey man
that that wasn't real yeah this Jesse
guy is up front
yeah it was an inconvenient thing but he
did tell people he knew that it was
[ __ ] and then but they found that
about it it just felt like during the
interview he's just he knew he has to
just keep going at it
agents happy for him it's been tough to
double down double down down very funny
and he kicks assets we all like him the
difference is we all like Steve
Rannazzisi because we all know Steve
really well I've known him forever
Steve's not a good guy you've [ __ ] up
cuz he wanted to be liked for a second
and then and in that moment he could
have said I'm lying it would have been
really weird mmm he would have been
weird so he just you know he just goes
like [ __ ] his dad's volunteer
firefighter in Long Island like Steve's
a good guy he was bad a mistake and he
just never yeah he was like I'd be weird
if I say I'm lying now I don't know what
happened it's [ __ ] what Steve did
boss showed no one he didn't involve
anyone yeah he was why say that he
didn't involve anybody else and send me
on on this one then so uh Lance
Armstrong isn't like in between both of
those again again
Steve Steve made a bad decision for a
split second and didn't go back on it
cuz he was embarrassed Lance Armstrong
but you know well I don't I don't I by
the way I don't have as much judgment on
Lance officer at all you know why he was
in a sport where everybody was doing it
everybody that's not the problem you're
missing the point
yeah it's people show off when they said
the problem with Lance Armstrong as yes
peds are there but he [ __ ] over so
many people at Stern and bullied so many
people that's right sue teammates and
other people that
that went against luck so it's a
difference yeah that by the way that's
some dark [ __ ] that's dark [ __ ] - that's
like Barry Bonds suing the other
baseball players were like what the
fiery different very different than
Steve by far yeah they did Lance
Armstrong's a bit of a sociopath it
sounds to me like when he does that I
forgot about that yeah he sued he sued
of the teammates oh yeah bad on him it's
like double down here just double down
just like down like that though no I
think you're missing the point it's not
double down chin there's a point of view
point of Lance Armstrong there's it's
not double in town it's a it's what he
does yeah so he sued people everyone
knew he's on steroids he's like that's
final in steroids but here's what's
gonna go down like if you weren't part
of his team or gonna play his game you
lost your job you got kicked off and no
one liked Lance Armstrong I hate it like
an other cyclist from other two use and
no one liked him really nobody like
Lance Armstrong no one but no but jesse
has nothing there's no doubling down -
there's nothing double down on this is
the story this was his plan he didn't
think we'd find this stuff out like now
if he comes out with interview later
today and goes I don't care what you say
it still happened that would be doubling
down all right if it never he comes out
he's like nope did happen I don't give a
[ __ ] what these guys are lying that's
doubling down if he comes out and just
like I [ __ ] up yeah that's why the
best way to go about it for him yeah I
[ __ ] up on my career was not going to
a director I want to go
I thought pulling over I am so sorry yet
and then we just drop it people like I
[ __ ] it round but if he does double down
it's on I think he has to know he's
already doubled down yeah he's already
tripled down he's giving any of us and
cried yeah but that's something that no
that was all the plan that was all that
was the media the tour the media tour
that's all the plan
doubling down would be now that the plan
is foiled if he goes on that media
torrents like I'm telling you this what
happened they're full of [ __ ] that the
Chicago PD's trying to screw me over
that would be doubling down there's no
doubling down on this it's gonna be
interesting to see you just need to
issue an apology and I don't know what
do you do you can never get another job
really nobody in Hawley was gonna I
don't know it's tough reality show
afterwards i watch that show yeah
Tonya Harding had Riyadh
I think what else you up this Drake
boxing you want to seem hit that easy
I can re tell you where's he at
you mean like you Brian fight whoo
you're just gonna I'm out no I would
hate now he's just night-night trick
doesn't got hands well that'd be saying
that you just put like Kevin Hart shows
video feed him it's like there's sin
shape
I don't think Drake said hey I can beat
up [ __ ] Roy Jones you know he's
challenging me with that [ __ ]
actually people have DM this to the
fighter and the kid and asked Brendan
who do you think would would be better
in a match Brian or drinks all the bad
things all idea he put it in I am what
is this
cat just showed me this
yeah the trans who went I'll show you
this is ma'am this is hold on
is this a parody or this actually
basically no sexual strap I hit it
the Superman walk on gin Sarah oh god
just made my Monday oh we're having a
tie Lopez hey hey someone said you're at
your this looks straight out of 2009
with the will the real man please stand
up I might suggest testosterone okay
girl yeah yeah filthy Frank she sounds
hideous well she's a guy so catchy put
into teens who maliciously misgender me
so this lovely boy wants to kill all the
children who reject
speech a parody not MC ma'am every year
we stray further from God and sanity
which ever you believe in soon the world
would just go dark all right well I just
got the drummer for those 46 a keeps
going off beat them the internet stays
undefeated the only person miss
January's himself the RA is she's a man
baby this is what happens when okay
[ __ ] that's funny that was funny oh I
mean I I think this is a person who's
emotionally disturbed and yeah mentally
disturbed I don't think this is I don't
think this is about gender or anything
else that's just as somebody who's a
little bit noisy throws it's got some
problems Bell wants Spotify person's got
some problems ma'am ma'am has got some
problems
she will be known behind on a Superman
Superman has some problems I hope she
gets help yeah I like the kid work here
the game starts like I'm sorry bro
that's what I know how was that
was that a was that good rap I couldn't
even hear the rap I just the meter so
loud oh so bad yeah that is just about
it that was hilarious
listening to another episode of Fighter
and the kid please come and see me this
Thursday Vancouver the vogue theater
we've already sold a thousand tickets
and I think there are 159 tickets left
get your tickets at E fat K calm or on
my Instagram and then I got Salt Lake
City March 1 & 2 wise guys those tickets
are going quickly too
according to the last counts to get them
then I got Kansas City improv March 22nd
and March 23rd oh [ __ ] forgot about that
G FAQ a.com I am in Miami March 15th and
16th Miami Improv Washington DC and a
march 28 through 30 tickets at t fat K
calm this is the final kid we're out